le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
ils font la fierté de notre île et mène
au trésor qu'elle recèle
la réunion est traversé par 850 km de
sentiers
chaque année le département et ses
partenaires entretiennent ces pistes et
en ouvrent parfois de nouvelles à saint
joseph
le sentier des trois sources le sentier
de la prise et le sentier bérénice
viennent d'être réhabilités pour
permettre notamment le passage d'une des
courses du prochain grand raid
[Musique]
la bouche aujourd'hui raconté il ya 200
marchands tamar c'est à jean petit dans
les hauts de saint joseph que ces agents
du département et de l'eau nf entament
leur journée de travail permission
vérifier que le sentier de la prise a
bien été réhabilités ce sentier c'est un
sentier historique qui permettait aux
habitants de grand coude de relier en
passant par les trois sources de l'autre
côté la plaine des grègues et il s'est
dégradé il est tombé en désuétude
pendant six mois les équipes de l'eau nf
ont donc réaménager le tronçon pour le
rendre de nouveau praticable
on lève c'est un chantier disons qu'ils
se fait couramment mais avec malgré tout
des techniques qui ont été mises en
oeuvre
qui répondent un petit peu les
spécificités du sentier qui est un
sentier de remparts qui ont fait que on
a aujourd'hui certains ouvrages qui sont
quand même d'envergure bravo
en tant que représentant du département
christian est venu vérifier si les
travaux sont conformes à la demande
toutes les opérations que le
le département avait commandé donc sont
formalisées souvent une fiche action
avec un détail des quantités forfaitaire
ou unitaire de 137 marche
relâché en train de contrôler donc la
réalité des travaux
effectuer et notamment de compter le
nombre de marches qui ont été créés pour
les marches qui sont réalisés en boîte à
marans en bois local y en avoir 200 on a
ce petit outil très simple pour
comptabilisées par mettre un bâton à
chaque fois sur un pack les marches
comme les échelles ont été héliportés
sur site selon les recommandations du
parc national
ça a été des chantiers assez complexe en
terme de mise en oeuvre puisque il était
soumis à autorisation parce que les les
zones société en coeur de parc et des
milieux sont assez bien conservés au
maximum on essaie d'utiliser des
matériaux pris sur place
et puis quand c'est pas possible on
essaie de choisir des matériaux locaux
donc le bois tamara aucun bois noble si
les équipes se sont donné tant de peine
c'est pour répondre à une demande de la
population et notamment des
organisateurs du grand raid se sont hier
a été réhabilité de manière à créer un
itinéraire continue qui permet de relier
saint pierre et la commune de petite île
avec le grand sud pour remonter vers le
volcan l'ouverture de cette piste c'est
aussi l'ouverture de nouveaux horizons
pour les raiders notamment se disant
brocal la nouvelle course dit grand raid
cette année fait qu empruntera les trois
tronçons qui viennent d'être d'être
aménagé et donc permettront un retour de
la course en tout cas une partie des
coureurs sur les pentes du volcan
ce n'était plus le cas depuis quatre ans
[Musique]
partis la course disons vocale cette
année c'est le défi de mathieu et de
philippe
aujourd'hui ils font une reconnaissance
de sentiers avec serge un habitué des
lieux
moi je vous donne le sentier des trois
sources et le sentier de la prise
il les a déjà emprunté avant leur
réhabilitation
je le remet de plus d'une fois plus de
personnes sur la portion de détroit
source s'est légèrement dégradée bout et
on se demandait si réellement qu'ils
avaient la possibilité de faire quelque
chose sur un parcours pourtant c'est
bien sur cette piste que les randonneurs
arrive après quelques heures et même
dans l'effort les raiders apprécié la
beauté des sentiers super bien refaire
on a descendu encore 25 minutes je crois
mais tranquillement une demi heure je
connaissais pas et de faire les échelles
sont largement aidantes
donc je pense que oui ça nous ressemble
et qui est sympa et c'est passé c'est
dur mais c'est pas non plus très long
on a fait la descente la plaine des
grègues et on est monté pour la boule
marveaux g pour redescendre à trois
sources et des trois soeurs on est monté
par être au fond après six heures de
reconnaissance le groupe arrive enfin à
jean petit avec le sentiment d'avoir
fait une belle découverte
c'est magnifique c'est chouette je
connaissais pas le seul heureux qu'on
peut avoir c'est qu'on le fera de nuit
que l'on pourra pas profiter du paysage
mais ce chantier qui est magnifique très
dur mais c'est fabuleux
chaque année ce sont des kilomètres de
sentiers que le département et ses
partenaires entretiennent et restaure
c'est vrai qu'à la réunion nous avons
850 km de sentiers
nous avons environ 3 millions de
personnes qui se balade sur les sentiers
de la réunion
et aujourd'hui nous avons la chance
d'avoir une île qui est classée au
patrimoine mondial de l'unesco et qui
propose des paysages exceptionnels et
nous contribuons donc d'une manière
indéniable à la valorisation de notre
île
sur le plan sportif et aussi sur le plan
touristique
la réunion compte 850 km de sentiers
géré par le département et ses
partenaires chaque année trois millions
de randonneurs en train de ses pistes à
saint-joseph trois sentiers viennent
d'être rénovés par le nf le sentier
bérénice le sentier de la prise et le
sentier des trois sources
leur réhabilitation permet de recréer un
parcours continue allant de saint pierre
jusqu'au volcan
pour plus de renseignements vous pouvez
consulter le site du département au
www.cn.ca 4 point fr
[Musique]